hello everybody and welcome to pep talks
with the bitter Buddha that's me Eddie
Pepitone and this is my voice that is
now letting you know that you are not
just listening to some piece of [ __ ] or
some guy trying too hard okay real quick
London I'm at the Soho Theatre in London
starting next week May 12 to 24 and I
gotta tell you I am so the anxiety that
just pops me up now it's 6:00 in the
morning
and I usually get up at around 9 it just
pops me up at 6:00 in the morning going
I am going to die and that's how I feel
whenever I'm going on a long trip
leaving my two dogs and my wife leaving
Charlotte basil and Karen I don't even
mention the cats anymore because they've
become second tier anyway I'm gonna be
in London May 12th and 24th tickets are
going completely mediocre Lee so please
get that you know I'm a big name by the
way I don't understand it I'm a big name
among you know 30 to 40 people who were
depressed in an institution on the coast
of Eddy City then I will be at Just for
Laughs festival July 22nd to 24th I'm
doing a lot of shows there it could be
I'm gonna be on new new faces I'm 56 and
I'm gonna be on new faces and let me
tell you what I'm gonna do for new faces
I am gonna actually get a new face I'm
gonna wrap my face in gauze come out and
unveil the gauze and I'm just gonna have
like a broken face it's gonna be like a
weird soup and ticket links are
available on Eddie Pepitone calm and all
I can say about Eddie Pepitone got calm
is God helped that website just God help
if there is a God please help it in some
way because I you know anyway just go to
that website and just look at it with
compassion and now let's get to my I
actually have two guests the main guests
is
and I say this with all due respect to
the tertiary you know your place you
know your place b-team George Gobel of
podcast yeah my main guest this week is
a raconteur I was told to say you were a
raconteur an amazing and amazing and you
know you know and I don't want to get
too funny because this will make him
uncomfortable and it'll make me and
genuine but an amazing raconteur actor
an author now I you know there is a
triple threat but you are getting into
Nathan Lane territory who I saw and let
him in here this Patton Oswalt by the
way Patton Oswalt and his new book
silver screen fiend learning about life
from an addiction to film is available
now on Amazon
please welcome Patton Oswalt and the
other guy is his brother Matt as well
yeah who created putting a content that
still gets thousands and thousands of
what they call passerby looks and
YouTube money the YouTube money for
something like that the checks what what
you're kind of living pretty well for
that oh yeah you know I've been looking
at property in Malibu and Pacific
Palisades off based off my YouTube
revenue checks if she's been able to
he's been able to do the smart choices
frozen dinners as he's in the smart
choices immediately say can I
immediately say that one of the things
that separates me and you as stand-up
and success wise back to you and and I
and this is this is just a gift and also
for me just a tremendous family I'll say
charm I have a rageful hurt charm yes
you know mine is the charm of the
dispossessed like a lot of people who
are wandering the streets will be like
yes I relate to this fella or people
people on the periphery but what I love
about who's patent seriously is the way
that you just pull out an agent
did it right there smart choice as
opposed to Lean Cuisine that to me is a
stretch and I don't have the
concentration no I I know it's an easy
easy
but it seems that you just know a little
bit about everything do you agree what
is everything you gotta be on the micro
yeah no matter how many movies I've been
in I tried to lean back hunch forward
it's like a Michigan Mission Control
we're hardly not have already please
acknowledge this transmission hit your
speaker mic twice if it's not that I
know a lot about anything it's just it
we are so assaulted all of the time but
I don't retain it product Nate I wish I
couldn't retain I wish it would slip
away but it doesn't it for some reason
the rhythm of it really
I always responded really well to if I
ever had to learn something in school I
would do it as a song like like
Schoolhouse Rock it really helped me
memorize things so because it's always
jingles and tried away I think that
would be very funny if it was like
theoretical physics and you were
learning it by songs at and then the
boat tickets in a particle exists in a
vacuum like really technical lad start
in the core of the atom
let's go from micro to macro Galileo was
insane but let's not go into that
territory but I you know there are I
didn't even realize this I'm writing
something with it with a friend of mine
and he hired a there called naming
services and these are companies and
they use psychology and and they combine
psychology and I guess English English
degrees to create names for things that
almost form a little mini jingle in the
name itself and it sticks in your head
forever
like give me an example so they create
names for things I mean just just the
name of thing
the name of any um like like a candy bar
like KitKat that is almost a sound they
create a jingle so you'll remember the
name itself is almost a jingle the way
the sounds work right
KitKat yeah that just stays with you or
that you know if they stay with me yeah
you can no I mean I mean as dietary know
I you know when I see a cat as Pavlovian
you know when I see a KitKat I go and it
almost sounds like the sound of somebody
taking a crunch out of a delicious
chocolate bar KitKat like oh okay you
just remember that something so do you
respect marketing I know where I some of
the the cuz there's that phrase don't
smell it sell it when people work in
marketing don't submit in other words
this thing might be awful but our job is
to sell it and that to me is what's
wrong with the whole corporate culture
it's like look this may be displacing
thousands of people from their home but
we gotta sell it I mean something like
that our job is to sell it it works not
look the humanity is not part of our job
description no I have a friend of mine
that I grew up with now works at a
company that builds websites and their
current client and they were so happy to
get them because it saved their company
is marlborough because a marble they
can't do any cigarette ads in America
anymore in their entities because they
just shut it all down based not even
print I don't think you mall guys got to
do warnings warnings warnings however
all the tobacco companies are putting
all their money into third world
developing countries because they smoked
like chimneys and they sell to kids or
they openly sell to kids yeah try to
make it cool no you haven't
and here's to kids music and the whole
time you say I know it's awful but I got
see that is the dilemma and when are we
and when are we gonna stand up to that
kind of thing
does it can people just really walk away
can people walk away and go you don't
want I'm not gonna do this ad work I
think it'll be better for my soul it
depends on the person because there's
also you have that lie and I have fallen
for this lie of them if I walk Iranian
walk away now beginning of my career
it'll have zero impact so maybe if I go
along for a little bit and I build up
some fame and power then if I do
somewhat late but then sometimes you do
that and now then it's too late you're
too sucked in I agree and look Irie Irie
listen to the episode of you and Jimmy
door and oh that was yeah that was
amazing
or is on point I mean he has really like
his like I go in and out because I'm so
emotionally deranged that money now
being serious that my attacks on on the
world in the corporate world get get
sidetracked by just emotional [ __ ]
and I wonder if those stuff meet my
personal stuff really and I wonder and
and what happens is I doubt myself it's
like I'm like oh well maybe I'm just
being this bitter like I start to doubt
myself about my critiques right and but
Jimmy is like it's so tell me you lift
Reid listen I was reeling and he was
talking about you know the the anchors
on MSNBC and Fox and CNN it's all you
know they it's a wrestling match they
act like oh we're the liberal side where
the cancer side it is all completely
amoral it is simply based on on ratings
and and and I think that one of the
biggest examples was um the guy who is
that reporter who got Meet the Press
then he lost Meet the Press David
Gregory the Great yes he lost it already
yeah he's already gone and what happened
to him ratings ratings and also he it
was this thing where he used he was in
the White House press corps and he was
just a pit bull he would go after these
people he was amazing though and it was
made of oh god yeah the minute he got a
national TV show and
I call it the hope you can tell the
first one that they were allowed to fly
first class and you some people got away
I'm in long first class I love those
class but it's like some people are see
the honey trap that is it it is and
other people go I am NOT going back I
will do anything to stop from going back
to coach and they throw out all of the
right they take their fangs out
basically and it was just became and we
we love it it's Richard Pryor's
character in that movie blue collar
where he's this amazing agitator yeah
fighting for the auto workers rights and
he's really good at it
so was it be played by Pryor oh yeah
okay and that's an amazing movie Richard
Pryor Harvey Keitel and Yaphet Kotto
yeah [ __ ] I didn't know Keitel was in
that Oh whoo I love his traitor because
Keitel has this seething rage underneath
every way do you see blue-collar okay
but what they do with Richard Pryor is
they make him an executive and suddenly
yeah hey I think some of our demands
might have been a little crazy got maybe
we should rethink this a little bit Oh
suddenly yeah you mean like that's how
they'll that's one way to well they
co-opted it we'll see what happens is
that everybody gets bought out and you
know and this is the part of me that
goes well you know I understand it
because people want a good life they
want to raise a [ __ ] family exactly
they want they want to raise it and
here's the thing and they want be safe
while they're raising their family and
they want to have their kids in their
family but here's the thing I think in
the long run they're not safe at all
because the society in general below
them is [ __ ] deteriorating for
instance and this isn't to brag I live
on a park like on like like I'm across
from hunga Park there are now take it
easy you're gonna hear some things that
you may not want to hear you're up in
the hills a little bit but but on this
part there are no parking restriction so
there are about a hundred cars lined up
on the clock thirty of them at least
thirty of them have people living in
their cars and that's the type of world
and people don't see it they don't want
to see it yeah I don't want to see it
well and I'm out there with my wife and
dogs not too
that kind of lifestyle I'm out there
with my wife and dogs and I who is the
big like advocate for the indigent and
the poor I get scared of them because
I'm like are they gonna hurt my wife
yeah most of them are not they are gonna
hurt me there's a great thing well you
you have you have more meat on you
you're clearly that back and you can its
carbs I good protein in sugars that's
what they need they don't your wife is
very lean not a lot - very true there's
a saying that Oscar Wilde he toured
America and they asked why are Americans
so violent and he said and it sounds
like a joke at first he said oh because
you guys have such ugly wallpaper that's
why you're so violent haha but what he
was really saying is if you surround
people with ugliness it can warp them
mentally and yeah you know so when you
see these people they why are people
need excuse me
first it always starts off with these
idiots going blacks in the inner city
they're so violent they they go right to
violence bla bla bla and then these
white industrial cities began to crumble
you know our manufacturing base and
suddenly because they take it overseas
yeah but lo and behold suddenly white
people in poor areas get really violent
and turned into Oh would have imagined
alula if you surround people so drug
addiction and goes across the board
exactly but what I'm saying is if you
surround people with just ugliness with
concrete a true duelist architecture and
just garbage everywhere cigarette it
just turns their boards it's just it
literally changes their personalities
they're just angry all the time
right now it makes them pissed off and
people that can live in these gated
communities and can afford to pay
someone to make their visual
surroundings look good mm-hmm there's a
point so now why are people poor people
so violent trial it live in a poor
neighborhood for a week and see what
your mood and see what you how you feel
psychologically at the end of it
absolutely you won't be a different
person it is an assault you know what
I'm always amazed that is in poor
neighborhoods just the tremendous amount
of strain
than hope and goodness and goodness that
goes through people well that's that's
where you see where the real really the
the kind of the elevated the elevated
examples of the species actually are in
those neighborhoods where they are under
constant assault artificial light dome a
transcendent ya know real darkness at
night no real sunlight during the day
because of the shadows of the buildings
so your everything is thrown by the way
you play they go they they rise above it
you're basically describing a lot of
industrialization you know what I mean
and have you felt it have you felt it I
sometimes feel I so need to get into
nature have you felt that not only from
the surroundings but the computer stuff
like I I've been talking about this
lately on stage not to break again then
I have a forum but I talk I talk about
this the funds they said when I go into
the computer and you may be different
because it seems that you produce so
much through it and you're very int I
don't know you seem to be like one of
the impresarios of it but I go into it
no serious I go into it and after two or
three hours if I've been on it I just
feel like this emptiness well you know I
I feel like a Rando in na in Apocalypse
putting my like we are the hollow man I
had 10 likes on Instagram well a lot of
times when I'm online and when I'm you
know either arguing with someone or I'm
trying to think of something a look at
so yeah you got into it with peopIe yeah
but I'll notice that oh I haven't really
been breathing I literally stopped
breathing and I get so tense and I go
wait a minute this is it and then it
affects when then when I start writing
cuz I write on a laptop I won't breathe
while I write because I have the same
pitch now I'm and then I'm like oh
writing is such a chore no it actually
isn't if you would just calm down and
treat it like the treat that it is it
people now stir right wait for relief
not to whine themselves up what happened
there because I also but I've been
reading books about writers that writing
is always torture I have read about that
like that's not native like all you know
have you read that riff that most
of writers maybe I'm just talking about
novelist go through a lot of [ __ ]
yeah you live in your head all the time
yeah and also writers have a higher
instance of percentage of going crazy
because to write truly well guilty as
charged do you have you have yeah come
different personalities while you write
if you want to inhabit a character but
that can be liberating to be liberating
but it could also be very risky in the
long run because you begin your own
personality begins to flicker after a
while because everything on so many
different personalities especially
writers who excuse me my god he can
listen look at all the different voices
that he or she can write she's a she's a
white middle class woman but she really
nailed this black teenagers voice huh
and then male nailed this aristocratic
Iranian businessman how did she do that
she did it at that kind of at the risk
of her own sanity a little bit well and
and not to brag but don't we do that on
stage not mad don't we do that on stage
we so know because I like to go and I've
seen you to two men I mean just go into
characters go in and out of thoughts
real quick and you have this problem you
leave the stage you know you get off the
stage you go back to the hotel and I'm
just wired yeah yeah I'm really really
wound up especially because now hordes
of all the circuits that have been going
yep and I go into the audience more now
I have you dude I really tried talking
to people because I was I hit a wall as
far as my material was concerned where
it seemed like I was looping back and
it's a narrow subject anymore and what
is right because you find look
developing yourself as a comedian is a
humiliating process all the time we miss
you miss you miss you miss you miss I
didn't get it so when you start figuring
out your voice and what works for you
there's a part of your ego and pride
that goes I want to cling to not being
humiliated anymore and not going into
new places where I might look stupid
here and so you then stay in comfort
yeah you then stay in the comfort zone
as you start to hate yourself yeah
because because and I'm at that stage I
have been
to h3 but when I was cognizant that I
was separate from there were those two
golden months from like two and a half
that's when you turn three we really
think I'm really self actualize and then
oh boy
you could just go back to two and a half
but you're hitting on so many things man
yeah yeah now what the amazing thing is
and I and I'm kind of doing this - but
it's walking through all this stuff
that's amazing yeah you like to like to
do another hour and you are prolific how
many hours have you gone I'm well I'm
doing another hour in October so I think
that will be my seven oh my now I
seriously don't know do it I am working
on my third and it's just paint it's in
that place I'm going to London and by
the way I'm very scared because it is
different thing I did two weeks or did
two what we'd like to use it was so much
fun that the crowds there are so
literate even you know they they just
have a not not even in terms of
intelligence just in terms of trying to
be aware of the because they live in a
much much older country than we do and
they have been humbled and then came by
Brahmins I know but but but by which
weird about um they went through one
more - man World War two they saw the
collapse of their empire basically with
the swing you know they want we had not
seen ours yet we have well in the middle
of it there's something we were so close
we had a chance at the end of the 70s I
know things seem very grim but there was
a humbling about to happen and if we had
just gone through it and got it we would
it be a but end of 70s the very very end
and then we all just turned to Reagan
and just went yes everything's great and
forget all that crap are you talking
about Carter those larger yeah he was
talk about a guy it was like I just want
politicians to tell me the truth and
here came a guide that for better or
worse told everyone the truth everyone
[ __ ] off get out of here you know they
want the American psyche and it still is
like this we want to win all the people
to and I was reading my go-to guys a guy
named Chris Hedges who's really he's in
this school of father beragon like oh
you know him - I know him I've been
trying to we I've been talking to his
producer we're trying to figure out
right how'd it go on his show he um
yeah he's he's great I love Chris Hedges
he's a mate he's he's unrelenting like
he really does say no no I'm not gonna
sell out to that I'm not gonna get a bit
of comfort but um I brought him up
because why did I bring him up do you
remember well just about you said
America wants to win and I will further
I don't I don't even think it's a want
to win thing we don't mind a little your
thing we never want to be humbled and
have to go hey I was wrong and I just
learned something and now I'm better for
it
I'm better for being humbled and now
that I'm humbled I because because
nothing into any comedian will tell you
you never be truly become a great
comedian until you are absolutely
humiliated and fail onstage once you get
past that failure then you're like oh
okay now I can I can deal with it
I find that happens in increments I find
that they're a failure like I felt a big
time younger yeah and then yeah but now
I'm fine but what I'm saying is now
people are trying to engineer it so that
that never happens
more if it does happen then there's this
vengeful triumphant comeback there's
vengeance and I think vengeance is even
more dangerous than winning because it
makes people do a lot of [ __ ] for the
wrong reasons look think of all the
comedians we know we could name them
where their whole career is basically
about vengeance you can literally see
them going that open mic back in 1991
where they hated me won't they're gonna
[ __ ] no you know what
first off they were right you weren't
who you are now you sucked back then
just yeah roll with it
yeah I'd enjoy what you're doing now but
you see so many comedians that their
whole thing is
engines well they feel like they were
ignored and stepped on when they do well
that's what they were yeah that's how I
know you're talking about the psyche of
a comedian
yeah well the noise again not all
comedians I know plenty of comedians
that laugh at their mistakes and also
the healthy ones man and those the ones
that go on to better and do even stuff
because they have lucked people that are
doing it out of vengeance what they've
never lost is their fear of failure in
their mind and you got absolutely how do
you lose the feel of failure by just
letting it wash over you like letting up
and waking up the next day and the world
didn't change and the world didn't end
and also you got to do the same thing
with I think massive success can [ __ ]
people up but though I was gonna say yes
Madison they wake up the next day they
go everything's different tomorrow nope
you're still you you gotta go now you
went through that I thought you know I
have little successes both in such huge
ways it's an interesting no because I
find you know I always thought well
success will be great but success has a
whole nother set of problems
one of them being it's exhausting oh no
no my bonus thing my biggest thing is
I'm learning how to say no it's very
difficult with with social media
everybody is asking me can you do this
can you do this can you do this and my
first reaction since I had a fallow time
equivalent to like a Stalinist five year
period what you're gonna say it's like I
wanted to do I want to do every three
years of not only know but going in and
auditioning and trying and they're just
like no you not that and then for the
first time probably for the first time
this last year and a half and that's the
first time in my career I was offered
things I was actually really that just
thought I heard things yeah yeah that
reason I mean and so is it that the but
now once you get all four legs and I
don't want to audition anymore well no I
actually like auditioning you do because
you have to make decisions and a lot of
your talent comes from your choice and I
like the thrill of that I have no
problem auditioning but for the I'm not
saying I'm offering everything no I know
I'm saying that you are the first
you that you do when you get offered
something as you remember the years of
nothing
yes yeah I don't care what then I'm
overextended and then I'm anxious and
then I'm sick I'm sure that's exactly I
mean I got physically sick this last
time doing the combination of promoting
my book flying back to Baltimore to
juvie is this recently here did you
justified dude bad for Jewel's now I
want to ask you I base it anywhere the
family I have a wife I have a
six-year-old daughter that I want to be
with and no I'm serious
that is a tremendous stress oh yeah and
everybody's like hey it's good to be
busy well there's got to be a balance
you also have to you can get so busy
what was happening to me was and again
this is about oh my god I totally failed
at something I failed at juggling all
this stuff I I hit a wall and I screwed
some things up and I just couldn't do it
what happened did you have to not do
some things yeah I had to either not do
some things and a couple things I think
I ended up doing but it did them very
badly that hurts and I feel like crap
but and I also did some stuff where I
wasn't there for a thing with my
daughter or a thing that my wife needed
because I had said yes so a lot to go
self-aggrandizing egotistical [ __ ]
but here's but again seeing the
frustration that that caused and people
that I care about and then seeing the
the the disgust that it in front of me
I'm glad for that because I can remember
that now and now I'm able to say no
easier boy it really is a freely
trial-by-fire process where you have to
go through the fire to then go while I
don't need to do this well can I tell
you something else this is really
interesting my wife isn't is a true
crime writer and she's writing love it
yeah well she's writing this man I just
think it's so funny that's what murder
it's a funny thing
yeah and obsessed with solving them like
like talks to just leaves now that is
that scary
a little like honey this guy isn't
coming over is he like like a three time
that serial killer
hi Patton its Frank Johnson I killed
three families in Kansas City are you
the in cold blood guy no no no there's a
part of Kansas City first off that much
respect for your wife's work but I'm
gonna have to a Skinner and make her
into an overcoat could you just hold on
I'm on the line with justified
you can't even deal with that threat to
your wife let me can you two seconds let
me get rid of Timothy all from the other
oh by the way is an angel yeah an
absolute you want me to say hi for you
tell him I'm gonna kill him and his
family you got so loot like watch
Deadwood first agree with that otherwise
but but but she said look I need and and
I really innocence because I need time
of I just need unbroken concentration
until I turn this book in which will be
in July and so I just need you not to do
I'm just asking this and this is all you
not to do why didn't you take care of
the can don't yeah yeah you need to take
care of the kid just have her so that
all the days are unbroken right
basically right unbroken I too heavy
handed a movie but go ahead well so
that's kind of what I'm doing and I got
to say taking stepping away from
everything and saying no to a lot of
stuff ends up you I'm now starting to
create stuff in my own head that I can
do because I'm not pursuing other
people's dreams yeah you know I'm always
grateful to be asked to do anything
right for a while it's like what are you
the reason that you're using other
people's projects and dreams yes and the
reason that you're being asked to do
those projects and dreams is because for
a while you worked really hard on your
own stuff yeah so maybe you need to go
back to doing that for a little bit yeah
because if you don't because there's a
lot of people that's got George Mayer
who Simpsons writers genius and he said
something really wise to me goes all
those people that say well I'm just
gonna I've got my thing I'm gonna do but
right now I'll just take this job for
the money I'll write this crappy film
around this awful TV show just to give
me the money to work on my own thing and
then
this time welcome another thing they
turn the tap on nothing comes out yeah
they blew it on everyone else's stuff
see that's what translation not [ __ ] pep
talks [ __ ] my even here this sucks
doing you a huge favor goodbye
no no that's what I try to make pep
talks it's like this is this is gonna
fill you because no it's talking about
the important stuff and I don't think
about the important stuff this is this
is also what's really sad is one of the
one of the biggest helps that I had
coming up was sitting down and talking
to my comedian friends when I would get
into these jams but now they all have
podcasts so it's like I got a book
myself on your podcast ticket yeah yeah
well you talk to community friends
without podcast to hold that yeah but it
would be funny if every time you had to
talk to Brian boasts a but there is let
me just get this hooked up past I really
uh sounds a really suicidal thoughts
last night can you get to the in an hour
I can have the guys down there will do
that can you tie it in with with Steven
Seagal's on dangerous ground I'm gonna
jump off the Hollywood and Highland
building let me get a camera down there
right that would be a live streaming
thing let me bring the puppets so yeah
there was that kind of interesting yeah
you know there was a little bit but I
mean you know I get you have to just
jump into things and do them wrong for a
while I mean I what I also realize was
that is what's and it's it's not gonna
stop me this year this is your that I
start I was always you know I always
wanted to make films and okay I gotta
start making sure why the way don't
these nerves go by very quickly well
we're one [ __ ] may I'm like whoa yeah
remember why here why they go by so
quick I didn't ever thought of this my
wife pointed this out because as you get
older there are less and less new
experiences for you to go through like
when you're young
everything's novelty so a summer feels
like it lasts forever and when is
Christmas gonna come oh my god and now
the same
but because you also as a results to be
a success you got to do the same stuff
over and over again and that was your
meeting responsibility exactly so that's
why by the way that's December whooping
oh my god
not only is it [ __ ] December but I
got a shitload of things to buy yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah you know what I
mean
but yeah so um there's that going back
to the humiliation and vengeance is you
know when I start making some of them
are gonna be really shitty and some of
them I'm gonna have to get a lot of
people together and I'm gonna make the
wrong decisions and waste people's time
and I gotta be an idiot for a while when
you're the guy making the movie you
don't get to be the cool one you know
cracking jokes and yeah what you gotta
be like okay guys can we and a lot of
people were you making a movie your own
movie now I'm gonna start making some
there's some short ones I'm gonna make
em and I have you're building up to do
your own thing
that my short ones will be my open mics
that's how I think of it okay gotcha but
there's gonna be times when oh boy that
was a waste of a few days but I gotta go
through it I gotta go through the
humiliation I gotta be humble
it takes a if you want to truly be a
great cleaning you gotta be humble have
you got a great anything gonna be home
this may be a naive question but have
you gone through a lot of humiliation on
stage Oh Oh God not only know it's
encouraging to hear that's a great
section I went yeah I was so not only
was i humiliated on stage which is which
is bad enough but I've been humiliated
hanging out with comedian friends my it
was not the funniest guy in the room
you're not clicking and you got it but I
there's but but there's something great
about that I fell in with the group that
I fell in they're all 10 times funnier
than me and it made me work harder to be
funny
so I can hang out with these awesome
people there's nothing I see so many
comedians they only hang out with people
that are less funny than them or less
successful so they can be the alpha dog
and they don't grow hmm and it that all
comes out of fear but you can't anyone
with your four walls like your worst
beat down on stage well yeah the one
that November didn't you imagine
something up in San Jose
years there's a comedy club up there
where you were banned from or something
cuz the woman didn't like you or and I
don't remember okay maybe I'm banned by
the way I've been banned from three
different comedy clubs
Harvey's and Portland roosterteeth
feathers and the rooster feathers and
that was very hopefully that's you know
you know the amount of people that would
come in they didn't really get me you
know you know all that like like the
humbling that goes on is that I know I'm
really really funny
but sometimes in practice when you're in
a club that doesn't fit you or whatever
I your funniness turns into this look I
don't know what it is yeah and it makes
you question what you're doing
absolutely if this is a mainstream club
in there just to maybe I shouldn't be
doing what I'm you know exactly I'm like
well how come I can't I shouldn't be
Seinfeld rings in my head for some
reason it's not the audience's fault
have you ever here let me say that you
know it's your job to make them laugh
you know the most part I actually do
agree with it but there are exceptions I
think so you know and I'm sorry if you
are if they have you out at one of those
MTV Spring Breaks events and you're in
the sunshine I always am it's the it's
the audience's fault there's you know
and it's the Booker's fault for putting
you in front of the wrong people
absolutely no but but but I was going
back to Russia feathers Harvey's in
Portland and Matt's British pub in
Richmond Virginia banned from all three
for the same reason the club owners mom
didn't like me in my career then again
what's to happen
that I would have mentioned that happen
early or some of that not so well the
last one was in 94 that was Harvey's the
guy's not an important and look it match
British pub I was having trouble I
wasn't doing great and the mom just
didn't like me personally and rusik tea
feathers I was kind of a you know it was
a little bit good a little bit bad what
you know it wasn't my crowd I wasn't
there comedian you know fine Harvey's I
will I can say this objectively I did
great and the whole show was great it
was me Kurt
weitzman and this guy named tree and it
was it was it's Portland in the mid-90s
it's just perfect and all the guy was
like well my mom thought you were very
mean and you curse
too much and I was like and that was the
only time like I I'm sorry I destroyed
in front of that crowd and then the guy
said that's not important who is
basically basically Anthony Perkins
living with his mother you would be wise
to do his mother said his mother is dead
by the way for years you know that so
that was really creepy so that I've had
yeah yeah well it's just encouraging to
hear that you have gone through that
because you know you're at such a level
because one of the things I find is is
that I have a lot of trouble accepting
failure in the moment well no I mean
when things aren't going identity attic
but when you panic what do you do do you
attack the crowd do you I've done that I
have done that and and and that is so
horrific like that's the worst choice I
have realized as I've gotten older like
like like when I catch about you I can
see that your legs are kind of deformed
under there like just it's horrible you
know but no that's the worst choice you
know I remember what it's just that
losing because what we do and this is
the [ __ ] paradox of it about going
through failure because what we do
I think just takes so much confidence in
bravado ya know I mean that's what we do
it's all about being up there and going
I got something that you you're gonna
want to hear exactly yeah it is so good
when that leaves us think of how humans
communicate with each other and then
think of the form of stand-up comedy is
so at its base it's unnatural it is an
onion if you gather a bunch of people
together
everyone but him we're all gonna listen
to him and he or she is gonna lead us to
where you know to something and we don't
and and you gotta pay for it
yeah and you don't know where this is
gonna go by the way I think that's
unnatural and it's so like I said it's
total Brotherhood
I'll be the guy that gets up there yes
that'll be me that's that sometimes I
realize that before a show and go whoa
I've had this do it earlier in my career
I kind of just am more of a professional
now where I go okay I got a show I got
to do it but I used to go before a show
I used to be horrified going with the
thought of this wait a minute I would
hear the roomful of people sometimes I
get nervous when I hear them talking I
listen to like is that like you ever do
that behind the curtain and be like wait
a minute that guy sounds angry in the
front row I I actually live to the tenor
and then I'm always surprised because
when I get out there that guy who I
thought was angry is like I did when I
did my special I think it's my weakness
is strong I think I just did it in DC
anyway there was I was up there on stage
and there's a guy in the front row and
maybe like the third row but I can see
him so clearly and he has this big thick
beard and he total stone expressionless
face just no smile nothing just staring
at me
not even frowning just flat and he never
want literally never made an expression
the whole time and I started freaking
out a little bit like what why is this
guy you know cuz he also seemed like
that'd be my guy that would like me he's
kind of looked like kind of a Brooklyn
hipster yeah yeah and he's just staring
like yeah I'm so hypersensitive to
judgement by people that are hip or
intellectual I just go [ __ ] you but and
it so it flipped me out and then there
was we had an after-party is receiving
now this is like my third special I
think two years ago my weakness is
strong yes so then at the after-party
this guy is there at the after-party and
he turned out he was a friend of the
road manager and the road manager not
with no malice didn't think that through
but sat him in the third row because
my friend gave him a prime seat and he
cut the guy with the brick amigos I have
always been a huge fan of yours I am
very glad that I was like whoa and then
my firm was like yeah he's on the
spectrum he's a really nice guy but he's
on the spectrum but what's the spectrum
unlike almost like for autism oh that's
a really nice guy and and turns out
really intelligent really sweet but just
does not has zero effect and in he was
like I have been a fan for a long time
it was it Lily was this monotone and and
so part of me was going well that's on
me for flipping out about that but it's
also kind of on the road manager who
should know better to have a guy that
you know has no facial expressions yeah
don't sit him right in the front where
your guy can look at him and freak out
but do you think the road manager is so
busy with other [ __ ] that he I think the
road manager was genuinely being a nice
person and that's my friend I want to
make sure he is and he's a cute like
there was there was absolutely no malice
in it but there was there you can [ __ ]
things up by being totally sweet if you
don't think [ __ ] through yeah you know
that is an amazing thing to that you do
that and I like if I look into the
audience and and and it's wild that
you're doing a lot of crowd work though
I I have done more but I still get a
little trepidatious about it because I
it's just like seeing some of the faces
that don't look happy yeah I used to get
I used to react like what's your like a
tenth attack dare are you why are you
here you know you could always leave you
know immediately the audience hates me
you know what mo are you kidding yeah
when you did Kearney Hall did you kind
of like peek out at the audience for no
you just did not want to look at how was
that experience
that for a second I just read January
you did Carnegie Hall January 9th yeah I
did Carter how the [ __ ] was that that's
that's a [ __ ] milestone were you
nervous I was well here's what here's
actually worried about Carnegie Hall I
was a mess until I got on stage once
that sounds familiar once I got on stage
like well this is happening that's what
happens how there's that freedom
now it's truly in a way that before I
get on stage I could trip and crack my
nose something could go wrong I could
get nervous but now once a month stage
its rolling and we can't stop it and
it's almost like the audience is also
like we're all in this it's a guy alone
on stage at Carnegie Hall and you
actually have stuff on your side once
you get out there but the hours and days
leading up to it were having tour sure
is that for you sure I just I think a
lot of people are actually gonna be
inspired to hear this because I think
they have an image of you is just like
floating through you know what I mean if
I ever get to a point where I'm not
nervous before I go on stage I think
that's when I stop being a good comedian
when I because I give a [ __ ] about this
I want to have well and I want it to be
fun for me that you're Largo should you
do that you see we're so relaxed there
yeah but I'm always working out new
stuff yeah and I always make sure to
book people on the show that I think are
great and make me work really like the
last time I did it
bill burr went on before me so I was I
there for that one word god maybe you
know but I remember building going on
before you he's done a bunch of them and
okay and what you said was damn it I
should have had Pepitone well no I or I
should have had cuz one time louis c.k
dropped by and I said look Louie I you
are going on after me so please I just
work it out to do something like it's
too late for that
your louis c.k now just I think what's
funny to me is that I think you were
just that's your level like [ __ ] no no
no I think you've got [ __ ] that's better
than you know and that's why whenever um
borrow is a monster right now um that's
why I always I've been inviting Maria
Bamford to do my Largo so she's always
busy and I'm partially I'm relieved
because she's another person she would
have to go on after me and here's why I
would actually rather I'll tell you why
if I had to follow if those at who'd
rather follow on say it's Louie see Cara
Maria
okay here's who I'd want to I would
rather follow Louie than Maria here's
why cuz after Louie I'm not gonna do as
well because I'm not as funny a comedian
that's why but after Maria I'm not gonna
do as well because when Maria is doing
is so evolved and beyond what any of us
are doing that if you found I say one
little crease really quick if you cuz I
followed her before near the end of
comedians of comedy the word was out
about her and people just loved her and
you would go on after her and you felt
like mmm the Beatles had just done in
Sullivan and now you're out there just
spinning plates like remember when
entertainment used to be this had a bad
like you feel like this old baggy pants
comedian with a Seltzer bottle hey Mack
Oh cuz it's so this knuth and she gets
the audience of this other wavelength
and you just look like this archaic you
know oh don't say archaic and pretty bad
is it because Maria Maria does this
incredible like it
internal like dialogues with herself and
and but then also can go into joy by
going into other characters on stage and
inhabiting them a hundred percent and
and making the points and I say my only
problem with Maria and it may be the
fact that I have tinnitus which is a
condition that affects one out of four
comedians who floor sanded earlier in
their life I have ringing of the years
now so that's what tinnitus is are you
and Pete Townsend Wow he's a good buddy
of mine but we owe that gets a laugh but
we you know it's like a little bit of a
hearing thing I don't she speaks so fast
and the variations of her she goes up
and down does anybody else miss what
she's saying and I'm frustrated because
I hear the audience I don't if you don't
miss it
something's wrong with my hearing yeah
you're hearing sucks because she I mean
the minute she reminds me of when I'm
that story when Elvis Presley first did
his tour and he came out of that Million
Dollar Quartet member with with Johnny
Cash
Elvis Roy Orbison
and they were all good Costello it was
custody so Presley cisely
press hello but they said who do you
want to open for you he said anyone but
Roy Orbison is that way because Roy
Orbison would put the audience in this
otherworldly hypnotic mood and Elvis
would come out and we just because you
just feel foolish you just feel like you
feel like a clown and after Maria is
like her her comedy is just so I just
there's no other comedian I know working
maybe Bryan Regan's up there Dave Attell
Louie Bilborough right now we're other
comedians watch them and just go I've
got a right but what the [ __ ] is
happening like it's just this other
level it's just this other level that
you're looking at you know and and and
you don't the the at the very last
comedians a comedy show in San Diego I
closed it out but I followed Maria and
it felt weird it just felt like that was
the new and hey I felt like it was
Woodstock and they had Sean on uh follow
Jimi Hendrix I guess what it felt like
like he just sets fire to his guitar and
then you know who oh baby so do you get
inspired by these these people do you
get inspired to like go differently
different ways well just to push what
you do and never and what you really get
inspired to do especially when again
when I watch people like Maria how she
and it goes on to the edge with
characterization and Bill burr how he
goes to the edge with subject matter
there is no one that that goes to the
edge with segments and then um Louie
goes to the edge with personal
revelations it just makes you do two
things it makes you try to recognize
when you are repeating yourself and
getting into comfort ruts to cut those
away yeah and then it also the second
thing is can I take any deeper on this
yeah cuz bill burr that well he does a
whole bit Rees like there's there is
never a reason to hit a woman he's like
never like there's reasons you just
don't do it I saw bill at Largo with you
again I'm doing that again people gonna
hear that go what do I know
the way he does it is so brilliant he's
not well he's not and that's the thing
what he's doing is he's making fun of
the lane and how the language is being
misused that's the thing about all the
PC people who like put the clamps on or
like this guy said this what the [ __ ] he
shouldn't be in Ossipee
but you have to [ __ ] you you have to
know what is going on because I remember
a bill and this killed me and it also
inspired me because I'm like oh wow I'm
afraid to do these things
I'm afraid to offend you know people I'm
afraid to like step out of some kind of
moral you know toeing the line morally I
should be a good person because Bill did
this thing I don't know if you remember
but Ray Rice was caught punching his
[ __ ] girlfriend and part and it was
so all this domestic violence a
something that like you let me tell you
something
they're talking about taking away our
football now if you think you're getting
hit now it's gonna get a lot worse if
you take away our football and it you
see here's the thing about that you know
that bird doesn't really mean that
no no he's making a hilarious [ __ ] but
but there's a point to it there's a
truth to it because that's how you wake
people up and I think especially now
that the the again the extreme I'm not
anti PC I'm anti the extremes of
anything I'm not anti conservatism but
I'm anti Tea Party with their crazy
limited I'm my anti progressivism a
little glib realism but I'm anti the
extremes of PC they have won everything
out of context because that ruins what's
a good movement and and I think that
goes back to that vengeance thing where
it's not enough to I'm offended okay I
understand that it doesn't mean anything
but you can be offended all you want but
no I'm going down I want that person to
suffer because I'm offended say no you
don't you don't get to have that hey
I'm offended by Rush Limbaugh every time
I hear him open his mouth I he needs to
be off the air no he gets to be on the
air and I
and I kind of want him where he is I
want to be able to hear that stuff you
didn't go because I can't why do Fox
News I can't watch I don't watch either
but what I'm saying is whenever I read
an article about you know some god-awful
yeah said people go yeah and he needs to
lose his advertising and Bubba bottom
like I would rather the horrible racist
be out of me open so we can see them I
don't want them to find more and more
clever ways to disguise their hate what
happened to Glenn back where is he
disguising his hatred well he bought
that he bought this giant um network of
his own online and now gets to pretend
to be this [ __ ] First Amendment
warrior when when really what you know
he needed was going cray
yeah they wrap themselves on these
causes that have nothing to do with I
want them out me open to for another
reason and it's I call it the uncle at
Thanksgiving reason where Rush Limbaugh
if you notice the way the country has
acted towards I went to the same arc
with Rush Limbaugh because it went the
same arc with Rush Limbaugh as I went
with my uncle Uncle Mike Uncle Mike huh
so when I was a little kid and I know
him better I loved him he was funny he
would say funny jokes here this great
then I got into high school and I got a
little more aware and I was like this
guy might be a little bit of a racist
sometimes I don't know about this dude
then in college when I was really
radical I would get into screaming
matches with him at Thanksgiving I was
just so angry yeah you racist piece of
[ __ ]
yeah and now I'm like hey Uncle Mike how
do what do you think of the the
Baltimore stuff because I just I'm
amused by someone here yeah I don't want
to see what you say you're not in
college
no what makes him Italy by the way age
by growing older and realizing how in
and realizing that these people are
speaking from fear and ignorance rather
than from power and I know people go
Rush Limbaugh has 4 million viewers or
listeners none of whom can really do
anything he doesn't he hasn't influenced
anything and what I what I love is that
the the the way that you see that the
country has evolved is the way that they
treated Rush Limbaugh's comments about
Michael Sam remember that the the openly
gay football player and they got drafted
I forgot Michael Shane got drafted and
kissed his boyfriend on Ravi when he got
and of course the next day Rush Limbaugh
said all this hateful [ __ ] and but the
progressive media's reaction was yeah
that's what he does he's just this fat
idiot who like but so in which the laugh
hang myself no you're saying not only
that just go oh yeah oh yeah that must
not even don't get so angry about it
just how terrifying must have been for
Rush Limbaugh to see the people that
usually are screeching for his mm head
just go [ __ ] idiot you know
absolutely that is what's terrifying is
when people just go of course that's
what you say that's what you say all the
time you're just an idiot like that that
is awesome guys don't mean that the Sean
Hannity's are the worldly they don't
mean that so they know because it's his
job he gets O'Reilly and me but there is
something visceral like when I have seen
Sean Hannity like for some [ __ ] this
is so hilarious I go to this one
pizzeria in [ __ ] Sherman Oaks and the
guy an old-school Italian guy has Fox
News blaring and I've never said
anything I want to go you know this is
the worst possible thing you could have
on but I just wind up watching it and
that kind of divorced state let the
little aloof stayed and I did but
there's something visceral about Hannity
where I just want to punch him in his
[ __ ] mouth cause you know why cuz he
is a he's a dumb guy that has learned
how to do that
dismissive mark professor a way of
talking but what he's saying is really
dumb yeah and she's want to know what
you're seeing it be like it reminds of
what's that that character that Zach
Galifianakis has the pretentious
illiterate which is a I told you I don't
know how to read condescending to you
and yeah and also he's always holding
that [ __ ] pen this hand like you're
not a report what were you doing you're
not taking notes or right here's holding
it cuz you like smart people pen uh pen
smart ah but there must be a couple of
issues that really piss you off in the
one you got a kid there must be a couple
issues were you like you know you can't
this thing slide out environmentally for
me is huge especially for the future and
I don't even have kids yeah
environmentally for me is really really
huge and and and what the one thing that
makes me lose my cool a little bit is
when somebody I I in a weird way I'm not
a I'm not as offended when someone like
Michele Bachmann says she doesn't think
that there's climate change because I
think she really is operating at the
height of her intelligence and she
sincerely believes even though it's
wrong what bothers me is when someone
like a newt gingrich who you know knows
better but he's saying well we don't
really know because he's protecting his
own job that to me is so [ __ ] evil and
that i think needs all that was like yes
you are you know better but you're just
saying this because you're trying to
appeal to your the people that pay your
bills you [ __ ] [ __ ] like that yeah
drives me crazy it's so sociable it's so
sociopathic and also there there is
something again it's gonna sound like
I'm going into PC territory but
especially because and by the way this
is all this is very narcissistic for me
to say because why because oh I have a
daughter so this affects me and it
affects her why didn't I why didn't I
have the empathy and imagination to see
this beforehand and I think it's part of
growth again just like yeah I guess you
and you'd like to think of yourself as a
better person and when you don't see it
in action some true I I do look back at
who I was and I just put on another
channel there are thing I never thought
I'd be this person but there are circles
and ways of depicting not just girls and
women I mean just
but like the they depict the process of
growing up sometimes in a really bad way
where it's about status and who looks
the best and who can acquire the best
stuff and I even see this in kid shows
and I that's something that I would like
to try to peel away and as especially
that's why I'm so I just think that a
lot of the anti-gay right stuff and this
this transphobic [ __ ] is just a mutated
version
of can't you just be normal this is what
everyone else is doing so you do that
you know I mean and and and that's just
as dangerous if you're doing it with the
anti-gay stuff yeah if people just boy
it's it's a mutated way of going but the
popular stuff is don't you wanna like
this is the majority in business and and
and and and it's a mutated version of
how they sell products to kids don't you
want the coolest new notebook don't you
want the best new phone you don't wanna
be stuck well yes they're selling to
kids no I know well that in itself is
awful that's and they start what's the
age you would know better than me oh
they start immediately and hideous is
until kids are a certain age I don't the
cutoff is they don't they can't separate
a commercial from the narrative that
they're watching they think the
commercial is another part of the story
and if you notice a lot of kids
commercials tell a mini story where in
the story the victory comes from getting
the product like ah now things are
better because we got this product it
has really insidious so yeah I try to
either show her stuff that's on DVD or
on Netflix with there's no commercials
or you know I just try to distract her
with hey let's build let's go build
something yeah let's go make something
let's go
you know is it weird I mean actually
sometimes it is I mean there there is a
parent I would fear that my kid is just
gonna get all this stuff because they
were around other kids firewall that but
it just you know sometimes you gotta
pick the kids think wow wow that's a lot
of we know but luckily we're very lucky
in that the friend she hazard like
there's this girl that lives next door
that does a lot of um sewing and
crafting she's a teenager but she makes
clothing and that so she'll come over
for playdates and she and without
gandhi's kid makes a practical she only
wears stuff that she homes penny do you
call your dogs and catch your kids are
you there yet are you
you know why do I take it for doing that
i I got some [ __ ] about that the other
day you know I and then I was like and
and I'm the tech guy if someone who I
respect tells me are you doing that then
I go oh maybe something's wrong to wait
but the way they sell the dogs now is
really insidious just get them that's
hahaha chuckwagon no but well I thought
what you were talking about is the dog
stores like they're over the top with
pampering them the opposite of what a
dog is a dog is a creature an animal
that runs in dirt and all this [ __ ] is
like put the little hat on them and you
know the roaming is out of hand there's
nothing like being in West Hollywood and
seeing a starving homeless guy in front
of the pampered pooch bakery they're
making high-end biscuits it would it
would happily eat a turd you know like
by the way I would side
me and my wife again not to brag
marriage me my wife went to Pasadena and
one of those gourmet dog shops brought
home really expensive treats come on
that was one day on a yard and Yahoo is
getting into [ __ ] don't they play a rate
for a pretty girl quickly we're running
the time do you want to talk about your
book at all well I mean I found that
interesting I was reading about it today
I haven't read it yet but that you you
kind of realized that wait a minute
maybe I shouldn't be that into these
films maybe I should get into real life
and I'm telling you if that was funny
and then we'll get to you with pudding
that was funny to me because to me
movies I want away from my real life
like like I when I turn on in and one of
the movies that was mentioned in this
article is really what Rolling Stone was
ace in the hole yes and I love base at
home you know Kirk Douglas and black and
wide and they take on some serious
[ __ ] issues about the medium way back
then way way back yeah I mean it was the
hole who directed that [ __ ] Billy
Wilder median it was caught and he it
was his follow up to Sunset Boulevard
actually to make the movie he wanted to
make and no one wanted to make this
script because it's so cynical and it's
about you know generating outrage for
nothing in the
cost someone their life base right and
so it's called a sim holders also came
out under the title the big carnival
another title another title however I
like big carnival ace-in-the-hole did so
badly that the slang for it around the
studios was a sin the ringer that's what
they call that's by the ways I you know
I always picture old Hollywood as not as
cynical as us so much more cynical
because you were just they didn't have
any other PC [ __ ] above their head you
worked for the studio they said no you
will go and you will be photographed
doing this Wow they told you you they
ran your life what you have to do
junkets to write where you have to yeah
but at least with junkets they're not
they don't show up the day before and go
here are three outfits pick one you got
to wear this on say this script you know
you can kind of talk and try and that's
why I said some of these junkets see
stars you know like that the robber
doesn't do anything like I'm not talking
about that [ __ ] goodbye you know yeah
you're allowed a little more autonomy
yeah yeah but sometimes I remember one
of these junkets for ratatouille we do
and a lot of them for that oh god that
was non-stop how was your breakout right
that was you describe that as your
breakout oh yeah yeah yeah that was that
was amazing by the way I was such a good
[ __ ] move well it's Brad burden Pixar
jeez yeah yeah but I mean I really
lucked out but I remember one time we're
talking is Janine and I and we're doing
an interview with this like Christian
family movie Network you know and where
I was with you here in LA it was in um I
think it was in San Francisco but it's a
we sit in the same chair and they just
bring people through yeah every five
minutes they just and now here's this
guy now and you just sit there and they
just change the background and they they
all get their footage and this guy was
saying um yes so in the movie seems like
the rat is sort of trying to seduce
Janine's character the woman I said oh
no not really he was uh as well I mean
he makes that guy kiss her it feels like
the rat really wants to I go no he he's
trying to do it so that he won't spill
the secret and then goes
but if he was trying to slick how do you
think he would go about why are these
people obsessed with lucking I was like
don't and and like I've never seen a guy
like his kind of kink laid bare and and
Janine and I got really creeped out that
I I wouldn't know how a rat would go
about seducing a human female and I
don't think that's what the movie is
about and I said well that certainly
feels that way to me okay well good luck
with your Christian family at work it
was that was one of the we are you
excited about are you excited about the
new Star Wars reboot I'm very very
hopeful I you know JJ Abrams seems
excited to be doing it he did Star Trek
right didn't he yeah yeah so he's got
good set agree yes he's got a good
record with the two movies I'm most the
three movies are most excited for this
summer let's hear it
Mad Max fury road you are holy [ __ ]
those trailers the trailers are great
and two friends might have already seen
it and and one of them this guy true
McWeeny who writes it HitFix
long he's not only did he love it he
goes I don't think people are ready for
this it just it amazing George Miller
who may be familiar ear and yeah and
it's all like prep mostly practical
effects like real stunts she's like you
can't believe
the stuff they pull off and it's it's
deep deep dark dark apocalyptical oh
yeah yeah it's again it's Los Angeles in
three years that's that's basically
water shortages and the other two are
Tomorrowland because again it's Brad
Bird that's live-action because
yesterday I went to the Avengers are the
new Ultron's good I'd like it well not
as good as the first woman it really
took over well I saw it in 3d did you
it's over no I didn't well that's our
difference in a lifestyles but it's it's
over well I don't have hot cast money to
blow on 3d glasses my friend it's
overwhelming in the sense that there's
so much color so much yeah I mean that
Tootsie
hello I got oh yeah well Mad Max is is
being shown an IMAX and 3d and I'm
holding out for that I'm gonna go see it
IMAX 3d and probably have an aneurysm
and then the third one is train wreck
Amy Schumer's new one that she wrote and
starred as in because so far on I don't
know if you watch her sketch show I
haven't seen it is the most the her and
key and peele are just talked about
constantly going to yet they just did a
whole episode the whole it's all one
sketch it's 12 it's called 12 Angry Men
inside of Amy Schumer and they're and
they're in a jury room where they're
trying to decide whether she's hot
enough to be on TV and it's 12 Angry Men
it's all in black and white she's not in
it she's only in it at the very
beginning and then it's just them
deciding like if you have a you have you
have a reasonable chub that's funny you
have to vote that she's okay to be on
television she's got some good writers
huh yeah but this thing just goes okay
I'm gonna check those directions have
never been on the shows either one of
those shows no but I love them you know
they're amazing and Toto did for her to
have the room to breathe and tell a much
bigger story I'm just like I'm excited
for a talent like that to get to do
something like that yeah yeah it pushes
the edge her show god she she did a
whole thing she did a Friday Night
Lights parody about football and rape
two weeks ago that was also one of the
funniest thing you gotta give it to her
she's funny I remember hanging out with
her backstage in a Chicago club I forget
what the name it was it was an offbeat
club and she was waiting to hear whether
or not that show was gonna get picked up
and she was and it did and she's huge
now putting let's talk about putting
what's going on with pudding putting the
cult head that now I don't understand
how it didn't get soul I'm sorry you led
up to that really badly you did a honey
sounded like can you do it cuz I weird
how many was sure and then you're like
now pudding like ladies and we're
talking about the food my brother
literally look like you got hungry and
anxious
can we talk about pudding I'm hungry
what is my favorite thing why my brother
is here and he does a web yes he did a
web series called puddin with starring a
methadone and we funny I say yeah we
tried to sell it a little bit that well
I was very bummed that it didn't get
sold I think it was my fault because I I
went this instead of trying to do it as
a half-hour of thing I tried to do it as
a 10 minute what we worked and it wasn't
but we were like boom boom boom boom I
thought it was perfect interstitial
stuff what is your opinion on this
yeah I still think that you should try
it as a half-hour show but each scene is
a lockdown set piece in other words
there's no coverage you just do each
scene and it tells a story but you just
leave it but it's just the punchline I
think that would be I think the best
matter does a half-hour show do is that
maybe like a Chris guest style
mockumentary where Eddie and I hmm are
do this web series called pudding and we
actually shoot some and the whole point
of it is to sell it and get a network
show and with some respect and dignity
and stuff and we just find ourselves
stuck in a web hell we just can't get
off this thing and but where's this home
and it's just about this the shows but
it's following us and this in this
miserable You Tube channel show we do it
I think it would have been too dark for
these networks some of the subject
matter was so incredibly jar commit to
the aesthetic of one camera lockdown
banker and Eddie just dealing with the
world and still find a way to tell the
story that way that would be really
interesting really hard to do that but I
think that mockumentary you're making it
way too complicated you're just adding
too many layers to something you don't
need to add guys too it's just the whole
but the whole lockdown thing you know I
would vans are putting that we had all
kinds of great guests Patton Robin
Williams
can you name Michael McKean who how
great is he on you better call Saul
forgot what a great actor he is oh he
was so funny on um on puddin and also I
still think
I move and I've said this a lot of times
before I love the movie this is spinal
tap and I know there's some all these
amazing moats that that are deservedly
well-known and beloved but the senior
the end where he's giving this it's
Michael McKean and he's doing this
monologue about what endings mean
because the band is gonna break up and
it's her last show and so he's on the
terrace that it is the most it is the
most beautifully idiotic thing I've ever
yes it literally means nothing and he's
saying it with this like I mean lay a
little wisdom on you and you got it
takes a couple nights watch but that is
the dumbest thing he's deceptively funny
with any funny yeah he's so funny and
he's great on that show
alright so that's in the works putting
putting look for putting in a new
variation of some sort I'm gonna guess
for today I think Matt's gonna go to
King Features and try to get it as a
daily strip syndicate next once again
putting turns into a game show where
it's me and then like priests who have
been defrocked because of molestation I
will I want to thank Patton thank you so
much for dropping by today about the
Goldbergs what the hell Eddie it's all
this [ __ ] we didn't I want to talk about
him all kinds of [ __ ] I got a costume
fitting and I didn't need to drop that I
didn't mean to drop that but I have a
costume fitting literally a sticky on
his phone saying drop costume alright so
thank you and Matt Matt as well thank
you thanks look you're going to have
such a great time I did it I did it for
three weeks
two years ago and the crowds were you
know like but you not in it not great
let you yeah yeah yeah great well thank
you Pat thanks for listening pep talks a
proud member of the OL things comedy
Network follow Patton on Twitter at
Patton Oswalt also go see him at Just
for Laughs or at Largo in New York at
Largo in LA and I do subdues a favor huh
scumbags rate and review us on iTunes it
really helps us out alright I mean do I
have to threaten you let me know what
you
think of the show email me at a Pepitone
at SBC global net and we'll see you next
week yay hey hey hey